decenas de niños afganos estudian en
esta escuela sus familias Se refugiaron
en Pakistán después de que los talibanes
tomaran el poder en su país hace 18
meses
[Música]
se va hussein es la fundadora de la ong
que escolariza a los niños de las
comunidades más marginadas y menos
favorecidas para ella es un honor abrir
las puertas de su escuela a estudiantes
afganos especialmente a las chicas como
estas tres hermanas que huyeron del
régimen talibán con sus padres y están
indocumentadas en Pakistán porque
vinieron acá después de la guerra los
talibanes tomaron el poder Y cerraron
las escuelas para niñas
ya no podemos estudiar allá cuando las
chicas salen las atacan las humillan las
insultanchín Martínez y en casa somos
solo chicas no tenemos hermanos no nos
sentíamos seguras
fue difícil tenían miedo sí mucho cuando
les gusta una chica no se toman la
molestia de pedirle su consentimiento y
se casan con ella a la fuerza aunque
sean muy mayores eso le pasó a una chica
que conocemos
todos los países están a salvo menos el
nuestro
me siento mal
vivimos aquí y vemos que todo el mundo
tiene derecho a la educación tiene
derecho a ir a la escuela pero nuestro
país está destruido y las escuelas
fueron cerradas más de 1,5 millones de
refugiados afganos se encuentran en
situación irregular en Pakistán no
pueden acceder a la educación pública
que es gratuita la escuela dirigida por
seba hussein es una de las pocas
opciones que tienen
nuestra escuela está abierta a todo el
que quiera estudiar no me importa la
raza la religión el estatus ni nada así
que realmente es una escuela humanitaria
Porque ahora mismo estos niños necesitan
educación
necesitan orientación necesitan
socializar deberían poder ser felices si
no quieren estar aislados
como muchos niños que estudian en esta
escuela Natasha y sus hermanas viven en
la extrema pobreza desde que están
exiliadas han tenido que trabajar para
mantener a su familia en mes y medio
tenemos los exámenes y pasaremos a
cuarto grado
gracias a Dios hagan su mejor esfuerzo
la situación en Afganistán no es buena
somos inmigrantes aquí y nuestra
situación tampoco es buena cámbiense
guarden sus mochilas y Prepárense para
ir a trabajar
todas las tardes las hermanas pasan
varias horas frente a este templo sufí
allí venden bolsas de pétalos de Rosa a
los peregrinos por unas rupias la
presencia de estas adolescentes sin
acompañante es muy mal vista en la
sociedad pakistaní patriarcal y
conservadora aquí los hombres no les
tienen ningún respeto aquí me siento muy
mal la gente no me mira como si fuera
una chica más sino como otra cosa los
hombres de aquí también me molestan
mucho y hacen comentarios humillantes y
menosprecio dicen que las chicas afganas
esto que las chicas afganas lo otro me
dan ganas de acabar con mi vida muchos
refugiados afganos se han instalado al
sur de islamabad donde la vida es menos
costosa algunos incluso han creado
centros de enseñanza privados como este
Las clases son mixtas las alumnas son
numerosas algo que sería inconcebible
bajo el régimen talibán en Afganistán
aquí las alumnas aprenden inglés con la
esperanza de poder obtener algún día una
visa para Europa o Norteamérica
Cuál es su país favorito
mi país favorito Es Canadá porque es muy
bonito
te gustaría ir algún día a Canadá sí
okay muy bien
me alegra ver que mis alumnas afganas
vienen a este instituto a aprender algo
siempre les recuerdo que en Afganistán
las chicas no tienen derecho a la
educación y que desearían tener este
tipo de oportunidades
les digo ustedes tienen esta oportunidad
intenten aprovecharla
me siento muy contenta de estar
estudiando de estar sentada aquí con mis
compañeros me alegra mucho haber venido
aquí poder continuar mis estudios
parisher volvió a estudiar tras pasar un
año y medio en kabul sin tener el
derecho a hacerlo su madre que trabaja
en la limpieza tomó la difícil decisión
de emigrar a Pakistán a pesar de su
precaria situación
Pensé que kaúl ya no era un buen lugar
para nosotros
y si mis hijos acaban siendo analfabetos
como su padre o como yo teníamos que
migrar algún lugar para que pudieran
estudiar y donde tuvieran un mejor
futuro es una carga pesada pero la gente
es capaz de hacer cualquier cosa por sus
hijos sin embargo para los refugiados
afganos en Pakistán la integración es
todo un reto muy pocos consiguen obtener
el estatuto de refugiados y acceder a
empleos cualificados